welcome everyone
and thank you for joining us for a
presentation titled
impact of segmentation quality on assay
endpoints
deep learning for high content screening
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
huwai long dr fuway long is a staff
analytics engineer at sativa a global
provider of technologies and services
that advance and accelerate the
development and manufacture of
therapeutics
her work over the years has mainly
focused on developing
machine learning deep learning and image
analysis
algorithms and software that help
address challenges
problems in the biomedical applications
in life sciences
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them through the q
a box our speaker will address those
questions following the end of the
presentation
please join me now in welcoming dr long
i will now turn the presentation over to
her welcome dr along
hello everyone welcome my name is fuji
long
i am a staff analytics engineer from
sativa issaquah
in big seattle area for those of you who
are not familiar with
us sativa provide technologies and
services to our customers
to help fundamental biological research
to develop
vaccines drugs normal cell and gene
therapies
we were formerly part of g healthcare
life sciences
and joined dynaher earlier this year
today i would like to talk about the
impact of segmentation quality
on etsy endpoints in high content
screening
this is the agenda and learning
objectives of today
first i will give an overview of the
high content screening workflow
then i will give a high level
introduction on machine learning
including deep learning methods
after that i will show how machine
learning and deep learning can help
high content screening then i will focus
on the critical step for the single cell
level high content screening
which is the segmentation step and
finally
i will use several case studies to show
how machine learning can really make a
difference
small molecule drug discovery can be
divided into two categories
target-based and phenotypic methods
target-based methods start with a
defined target
and identify compounds in biochemical
acids
because this exact target of small
molecule is known
lead optimization through the rational
design of molecules
is feasible however of target effects in
follow-up studies
can greatly impact their desired
efficacy
and add adverse toxicity
besides target-based approach assume
only one target causes
a disease phenotype and ignores the
complexity
of biological system in contrast
phenotypic methods start with phenotypic
perturbation of cell-based
systems and identify compounds in
phenotypic acids
these acids are used for high content
screening to identify compounds
in a more physiological setting
it typically generates large amounts of
data
that require much more sophisticated
analytics
including various machine learning
methods
today we will just focus on high content
phenotypic screening
image-based high content screening
workflow starts from
microscopy imaging the card image
are then processed by image and
analytics
image segmentation extracts individual
cells nuclei
membranes and other cellular structures
feature extraction then extract various
features
including intensity
morphological and other statistical
features
within individual cells or cell
populations
to form a high dimensional feature
factor
the downstream analysis then converts
the high dimensional feature factors
into interpretable and actionable
conclusions
high content screening started back in
late 1990s
in 1996 terry dunley and lindsey
taylor formed a company called the
cellomites
they followed a patent on image-based
high content screening
and got approved in 1999.
the invention screens a large number of
compounds using fluorescent labeling
and microscopy imaging
this approach however is based on
nuclear translocation
that is activated cytoplasm
proteins are transported into the cell
nucleus
where it can initiate transcription of a
particular gene or genes
this figure illustrates how to determine
the transcription factor distribution
in nuclei and the settle plasm region
using morphological operations
compared to what we can achieve today
this is actually low content
nowadays we can do much better obtaining
thousands of features
in a single cell for example in this
study
the cell printing assay developed by
broad institute
used six fluorescent stains to reveal
eight
cellular components in a single
microscopy-based
assay automated image analysis pipeline
was able to produce
about 1500 morphological features from
each cell
the protocol was later independently
adopted
at recursion pharmaceutical on different
disease models
today as the complexity is continually
increasing and outgrowing the capability
capabilities of the current analytical
methods
more sophisticated machine learning
methods are under development
and will bring high content screening to
a new phase
before i show you some examples of using
machine learning approaches to help high
content screening
let me give you a very high level
overview of machine learning techniques
today we talk a lot about artificial
intelligence
machine learning and deep learning let's
clarify these concepts first
artificial intelligence is a very broad
area
it applies to any technique that enables
computers to mimic
human behavior machine learning is a
subset
of artificial intelligence that enables
machines to improve
with experiences and deep learning is a
subset of machine learning
that uses multi-layer neural networks
there are different types of learning
supervised unsupervised
and semi-supervised supervised learning
needs data annotation
in the example on the left you need to
provide
the information that these four
red samples belong to one class and the
green samples belong to another
supervised learning needs a training and
test steps
typical examples are regression and
classification tasks
unsupervised learning do not need
annotated data
in the example on the right you do not
need to tell
which sample belongs to which class it
does not need the training phase
typical examples are clustering and
unsupervised
dimensionality reduction semi-supervised
learning
sits in between it uses both labeled
and unlabeled data it also involves
training and test
steps but has a lower requirement on the
amount of annotated data
and its quality many different machine
learning methods can be used
in high content screening for example
the regression methods including linear
and logistic regression
the instance based methods such as
support vector machine
k-nearest neighbor example methods like
boosting and random forest clustering
methods
like the widely used k-means and
hierarchical clustering
dimensionality reduction methods
including principle
component analysis and linear
discriminant analysis
and there are also base models and many
more
recently deep learning neural networks
have been used widely
in biomedical image analysis for example
convolutional neural networks have been
used in cell segmentation
recurrent neural networks especially
long short term memory
networks have been used in cell tracking
generative adversarial neural networks
have been used in synthesizing
training data to expand the small
training set
an autoencoder has been used to extract
features
now let me give you some concrete
examples of using machine learning
especially deep learning in high content
screening
in typical image based high content
screening
machine learning is playing critical
roles in every step
once images have been acquired we can
build
a classifier to do quality control
if the images have low signal to noise
ratio low contrast
or limited resolution we can use machine
learning and deep learning methods
to enhance images and achieve super
resolution
to segment cells nuclei cell membranes
and other structures
we can use computer vision algorithms
like region growing
watershed etc for simple problems
for challenging problems we can use deep
learning neural network
especially convolutional neural networks
to achieve very high accuracy in cell
segmentation
once individual cells are segmented we
can use computer vision and machine
learning approaches
to extract morphology intensity and
texture features we can use
dimensionality reduction
methods to map a high dimensional
feature vector
to a lower dimensional space
we can then use clustering and the
classification analysis
to find interesting patterns that are
biologically
significant in the following slices
i will give you some concrete examples
low signal to noise ratio images present
challenges to the downstream image
analysis
to get a high snr image you may increase
laser power
or exposure time however this will
damage the samples
limits the past possible duration of
recording
and cause artifacts and photo damages
this example shows how deep learning can
improve signal to noise ratio
computationally
in this study a group from max planck
cell biology
used pairwise low and high snr images
acquired under low and high laser power
trained a convolutional neural network
called u-net
to produce high snr image from a low snr
image the bottom left image shows the
low snr
image acquired under low laser power it
serves
as the input to the train neural network
the second image from the left is the
network
output the third one is the high snr
image
acquired under high laser power it's the
ground truth
and the last one on the right is the
restored image using traditional
denoising method
called non-local means denoising
this example shows that machine learning
methods especially deep learning method
can produce high snr images without
increasing laser power
or exposure time
deep learning has also been used in
whole image classification
for example human protein atlas project
aims to map the subcellular distribution
of the human proteome with confocal
microscopy
the current version of the database
compresses image data
for nearly 13 000 proteins each image
in this data set consists of four
channels
the antibody stand protein of interest
and three reference channels to outline
the cell
the human cell compresses many
compartments
here defined by 28 labels
the goal is to build classifiers to
predict
look the location pattern of the protein
of
interest this data set is challenging
to analyze automatically because of the
prevalent multi-label classification and
high imbalance of the 28 different
protein localization classes
to find the best solution for this
problem
a kaggle competition was held
it attracted more than 2000 teams
participants used the deep learning
approaches and
applied various strategies including
modifying
neural network architectures designing
effective loss functions
augmenting data and using pre-trained
models
the winning models far outperformed
previous efforts
at multi-label classification of protein
localization pattern
by nearly 20 percent
the previous example is the whole image
classification
in which structural segmentation is not
needed
let me give you another example on high
content screening
with segmentation this is a screenshot
of our high content screening software
called
incarta it has a rich body of analytics
modules
the structural segmentation module uses
machine learning based annotation
unit with resnet backbone and transfer
learning
to segment individual structures the
phenoglyphs module
is extract single cell-based features
and classify cells into different
phenotypes
with the combined use of unsupervised
supervised and active learning
here are some further details on
phenoglyphs
after structure segmentation using our
deep learning module
it extracts high dimensional features
it then uses unsupervised clustering
method
to assign individual cells to different
classes
which serves as our initial training set
and
initial classification model
then through active learning users may
iteratively
refine the training set and train the
model
by correcting prediction errors
in this example machine learning
provides an unbiased overview
of potentially interesting
sub-populations
it provides intuitive user experience
and more sensitivities to resolve subtle
phenotypic differences
from the above examples you can see that
deep learning
accommodates the added complexity in
high content screening
the downside is that in order for deep
learning to work well
one needs to have a large amount of high
quality
energy data recently there is an
increasing amount of research on
how to apply deep learning using weekly
annotated small data set
which is a more advanced topic and
beyond the discussion of today
so what approaches should one choose
should we always use deep learning
the answer depends on the balance
between the cost and reward
for small data set traditional machine
learning
is comparable to deep learning or even
better
as the scale of the data set increases
deep learning outperforms traditional
methods
and can produce highly accurate results
overall traditional machine learning can
take good use of small data set
has a lower requirement on hardware for
example
no high-end gpu or even no gpu is needed
therefore leads to a lower cost
it also has a higher interpretability
we know which features are important for
task and understand
why is that however traditional methods
produce
less accurate results they need
handcrafted features
and parameter tuning they also have
lower
generality on the other hand
deep learning methods can produce highly
accurate results
there's no need to do handcrafted craft
future engineering
or parameter tuning and the trained
models
can be generalized much better
however deep learning relies on big
and high quality energy data
they also have a higher requirement on
hardware
like gpu clusters and cloud setting
therefore they tend to have a higher
cost
besides they have a lower
interpretability
so the rest strategy is to understand
your problem well
and choose the right approach
having introduced machine learning
especially deep learning's roles
in high content screening in general now
let's focus on a specific topic
segmentation why is segmentation
important
segmentation is the first step in
extracting
quantitative information from individual
structures
erasing segmentation will propagate in
the downstream analysis at some point
meaningful biological results can be
overshadowed by artifacts
generated by segmentation
segmentation is also very challenging
this is because structures are complex
and objects are crowded images often
suffer from
low signal to noise low contrast
and are resolution limited
there is high phenotypic variability
generated
from natural population heterogeneity
and perturbation effects traditional
segmentation approaches have many
limitations
you need to manually define what
features matter
you need to define feature extraction
rules
algorithms optimized for one structure
may not work for
another and you need to fine tune
your parameters because they vary from
experiment to experiment from data set
to data set
as a result traditional methods have
limited accuracy
robustness speed and usability
the solution is to use machine learning
and deep learning techniques
to develop trainable segmentation
for example the 2018 data science bowl
challenged participants to segment
nuclei
in a variety of 2d light microscopy
images
without the need for any manual
interaction
or adjustment of parameters
this computation attracted nearly 4 000
teams
across the world top participants
succeeded in this task
developed deep learning based models
using resnet
backbone unit and mask rcnn
to achieve highly accurate nuclear
segmentation
the image here shows examples of
segmentation results from the top three
participants the first column is
original image
the second to the fourth are the results
of the top three participants
and the last column was produced by
self-profiler
profiler as the reference the
segmentation maps
show pixel-wise alignments between the
ground choose
and the predicted segmentation
white color codes correct answers blue
codes
false phosm negative and radicals false
positive
without manual interaction or parameter
tuning at
all these solutions provide more
accurate results
than traditional approaches
the most widely used deep learning
network architectures
for cellular segmentation are unet
and mask rcnn unet is a u-shaped
convolutional neural network
it has an encoding path a decoding path
and skip connections it has been
successfully used
in many biomedical image analysis
applications
using resnet backbone and transfer
learning
the network is able to extract more
generic
and meaningful features that are
critical
for challenging segmentation problems
mask rcn is another type of
convolutional neural network
it can achieve objects detection
segmentation
and classification all at the same time
it has also been widely used in
segmenting structures
from biological images
using the resnet backbone unit
architecture
and transfer learning we developed we
developed a deep learning segmentation
module
called cnap for our incarta
high content screening software
in order to segment cellular structures
from like microscopy images
synapse works with any type of data
including bright field images
it is highly accurate with both low
signal to noise
and high density images it copes with
high phenotypic variability
within a field of view and across all
plates
in an essay it's easy to learn and use
without needing an image analysis or
programming background
in carta synap has pre-trained
segmentation models
that deal with common applications
and can be easily tuned to work with
specific
biology problems
here is an example of cell segmentation
on the bbbc data set
using incartus cnap it successfully
segments each individual cells and
did a much better job than the
traditional methods we tried
here are some further examples on cell
segmentation
again they're more accurate compared to
some
traditional methods including watershed
and
random forest we tried there's no need
to do any handcrafted
feature engineering and no need to do
algorithm parameter tuning
to test the generality of synap
we further segmented the time series
like microscopy images
of wound healing assay of kidney
epithelial cells
taking the pre-trained cell model we
added a small amount of wound healing
acid images
and fine-tuned the model
due to some technical issues i'm not
able to play the video
here are some snapshots of the
segmentation at different time points
the neural network model precisely
separates the wound region
from the remaining tissue here is an
example of using synap to second cells
in the video sequence
from the cell tracking challenge again
starting from our cell-based model we
fine-tune the model using a subset
of the training data from the cell
tracking trimming set
when applied to new images our model
gave us
very precise segmentation results in
tracking these cells
this example shows a more challenging
scenario
on vector detection achieved by our
customer
grace pohan at the university of
california
at san francisco using our synap model
like most biologists she realized the
potential benefits
of using quantitative image analysis
specifically a high content screening
assay
that can quantify the amount of tobacco
formation
to infer the effect of a genetic
modification
or chemical perturbation however
her efforts were paused when realizing
she didn't have a way to quantify what
she could see by
eye the image on the right shows vacuole
is actually a very challenging problem
the wide
variety of vacuole sizes intensity
differences
and weak edge information all make it
very challenging for
conventional image processing methods
to make it even worse the nuclei exclude
fluorescent label and look almost
identical to the black holes by using
only her understanding of the biology
grace started from our preaching cell
model
annotated a small set of images trained
her own
model and had a working solution in a
very short time
within carter's synap she is now able to
get results
that even an expert image analysis
algorithm developer
would struggle to achieve as you can see
from this image
synap is a highly sensitive without
over detecting noise or structural
similar appearance
it is fair to say that deep learning is
able to achieve the best
segmentation performance for high
content screening applications
deep learning methods are more reliable
flexible
and accessible than traditional methods
there is no compromising or biasing of
parameters to one treatment or phenotype
it maintains high accuracy across
samples
with high phenotypic variability
a single workflow can deal with many
different applications
our deep learning tool can be used by a
novice
with no image analysis experience
trained model can be shared
and continually improve as they are
trained on more data
finally let me give you several examples
to show the roles of
machine learning on high content
screening end points
remember this image-based high content
screening workflow i showed at the very
beginning
image segmentation is a necessary step
to enable single cell level phenotype
analysis
the segmentation is not the end point
it's reasonable to question if
segmentation quality really impacts the
final result
errors in segmentation are often ignored
as long as the air is not
visually alarming indeed for simple
robust assays where high quality control
of
available and biological changes are
obvious
segmentation errors may have little
impact
however as we mentioned before errors at
this early stage
of high content analysis can propagate
throughout the rest of the analysis and
can
effectively reduce the ability to
resolve
subtle changes at some point these
errors
add up until you are unable to detect
or accurately characterize the
statistical
relevant phenotypic differences present
in the images here is an example
showing that accurate spot detection is
critical
in determining the agonist effect in
this example
changes in the number of spots counted
for cell
indicate a drug's ability to rescue and
induce the phenotype
in a dose-dependent manner we use both
deep learning and conventional
segmentation method
which is watershed plus multiscale top
hat to detect the spots in
acid with and without agonist
as you can see from the upper right
image conventional method
detected false positives in treated
samples whereas the deep learning method
produced the correct segmentation as
shown in the bottom right image
note that traditional spot spot
detection algorithm
requires you to optimize analysis
parameters
on one extreme condition test on the
other extreme
and then iteratively tweak the
parameters in this fashion
until a compromise is reached between
conditions
the bar graph on the right shows the
z values based on our deep learning
model and the traditional segmentation
results
z prime is a statistical measure
of how much two distributions overlap
in this case it measures the
distribution
in number of spots per cell across all
cells
for two for the two control groups
the traditional spot segmentation
approach
produced a much lower z prime value
compared
to our deep learning model meaning that
the segmentation errors in traditional
methods
lead to a situation where you cannot
confidently
determine the true magnitude of the
agnes
effect this example shows that
segmentation really plays a critical
role to the end point
the second case study will show you
accurate
segmentation promotes precise
quantification
of sub-populations in the downstream
analysis
researchers is studying sea applicants
which is the type of fungus
in our gi tract certain environmental
conditions will cause the east cell type
to transit to the infectious rod-like
structures
called hypha and pseudo-fiber
this study looks only at the negative
and positive controls in replicates
the negative control is grown under
normal conditions
where it is expected that most of the
cells will be a east-like state
a positive control is grown under
abnormal conditions
that stimulate the transition to the
elongated morphologies
the goal of the experiment is to
evaluate
if automated imaging and image analysis
can clearly differentiate between the
control populations
by segmenting individual cells and
accurately classifying them
as one of the phenotypic subpopulations
we segmented the images using a
traditional watershed based approach
and our deep learning synap tool as
shown in the upper left image
traditional method suffers from ender
and over segmentation
and sometimes it completely meets the
real signal
whereas our deep learning model produced
high accurate segmentation results as
shown in the upper right image
in a downstream analysis phenoglyphs was
trained
to classify individual cells from both
segmentation
experiments using the same set of
extracted features
colors in these two segmented images
represent
the class label where purple codes
pseudo kaifa and yellow codes hyper
the synap model results agreed much
better
with the expected outcome as you can see
from the bar
plots in the bottom right where the
negative control
is dominated by the east phenotype
and the positive control is enriched
with
the elongated forms in comparison
the traditional method deviates from the
expected outcome
as shown by the bar plots in the bottom
left
where negative control is dominated
by pseudohypha all the three types of
errors in the traditional segmentation
method
can account for over or under counting
objects
and can confuse the classifier the
classifier is
most negatively impacted by any
segmentation
where multiple cells or out of focus
signal
is merged into one object
the last example i'm going to show you
is the systemic
sclerosis high content screening
that was did by our customer a company
called
galactus fibroblast to myofibroblast
transition in short fmt
is a biological process in which
fibroblasts differentiate into
myofibroblasts and secrete excessive
quantities
of extracellular matrix proteins
it has been reported to play an
important role in late stage
systemic sclerosis
galapagos is using high content
screening to find
novel drug targets that rescue the fmt
phenotype in primary diseased human skin
fibroblasts they developed a screening
acid
the readout allows them to evaluate ecm
protein
production in response to c
rna perturbation the acid screening
plate layout
uses multiple replicates for controls
throughout the plate to observe the
plate and positional effects
they first used intensely related
measures
this did not yield a very strong pattern
for the
control wells versus the samples
and negative controls as shown in the
upper right heat map
using our machine learning tool
phenoglyphs they developed a classifier
that can successfully differentiate cell
types
and showed a strong separation between
the controls
the negative controls and the samples as
you can see from the upper left
heat map the figure on the bottom left
shows the heat calling using
phenotypic model produced by phenoglyphs
and intensity scoring model both
approaches
have a hit rate of 1.5 percent
but only 20 percent of the targets
overlap
the bar graph on the bottom right shows
the z prime score of
acid plates results obtained from
phenoglyphs was far more robust with
higher z
prime score than the intensity scoring
method
the machine learning based approach
represents more relevant targets
than those identified with
intensity-based approach
this improvement in obtaining relevant
targets
will result in fewer false positives
and allows at an identification of
targets
that would have been dismissed as
negative
by the traditional approach
to summarize machine learning especially
deep learning
are able to accommodate the increasing
complexity
in high content screening and are
providing
powerful analytics tools for drug
discovery
segmentation accuracy in many cases can
generate
significant impact to the high content
screening
endpoints finally here is a list of
upcoming webinars the next one will be
on
october 26th david andrews from sonic
brook
institute will introduce flim threat
techniques
there will be two more webinars in
november
one in december and one in january
please
save the dates with that i would like to
thank you all for your attention
we will be happy to take your questions
thank you
thank you dr long for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of this presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q
a box welcome dr long and i also
want to welcome will marshall who will
be joining us
for the q a welcome will
all right now ready to get here there we
go
welcome sir how are you doing thank you
for joining us
good thank you for joining us for the q
a
and um we'll we'll wait dr long we still
don't see you
and cannot hear you but while we're
waiting for dr long to join us
will could you answer this audience
members question what is the best
use of dl with regard to scale of data
and the audience member asks um includes
hashtag plates
yeah so i i think i would need a little
more
a little more um details to fully answer
the question so if you're
learning if i assume the question is if
you're trying to
basically learn um
the the features that best describe the
phenotype then
more data is going to be better but
within the context i think of a food
waste presentation
um it's just about training the
segmentation model
using kind of the transfer learning
approach that she
that she described then it kind of
really you can get by with a much less
data we're not talking
on the order of plates we're talking on
the order of
um fields of view to train a
segmentation model
um yeah but it but it's all quite
relative and
in our experience i think the answer is
you kind of have to do the experiment
because we're always kind of surprised
by
how we're not the best judge of how
complex a problem might be we kind of
kind of have to do the
do the experiment and find it out later
thank you so much and i think this next
question is also for you will
what quality controls are used to rank
the results from one application to
another
some may quite obvious be obvious to
others very subtle
how is this measured
what quality controls are used
to rank the results
yeah i'd have to i'd have to ask for for
some follow-up clarification i'm not
really sure
what results and and what the
the rank would be so is that assay
robustness
or yeah i'd have to ask for for some
more clarity
okay and then um i know we are still
waiting for dr long to come
back in um perhaps will you can help us
with this question as well
how many as well as what analysis
is done to show for correctedness
yeah so again i need a little clarity
but correctness
maybe model accuracy um so
if it's if we're talking about
segmentation
to kind of assess the accuracy of a
segmentation model
uh it's probably best for maybe maybe fu
way to take this one
uh i'm pretty sure that that she would
tell you
uh there is no agreed-upon best
method to do this but things like
mean iou or something like that to
really looks at
look at you know accuracy down almost at
the pixel level
um is one metric that people commonly
use
although it definitely is not the best
metric in all cases it kind of
depends on what your goal is
thank you so much and dr long i see that
we see you now
welcome back we appreciate you logging
out and logging back in
can you hear us now yeah i can hear you
uh can you hear me wonderful i can
before i get to a question for you
will the audience member that wrote the
previous question just clarified for us
what quality controls are used to rank
the results
from one application to another and it
was looking the question was really
about
confidence of the results could you give
us a little more detail on that with
that clarification uh yeah
so regarding the quality
control so one way is to visually check
of course we have biologists here
that work with us closely to check the
results
and so they can tell us whether the
results make sense or not
um we have some ex almost every
experiment that we try the traditional
segmentation method and deep learning
and we have biologists to tell us that
um which one
makes more sense uh that's one way and
the second way is that we have some
quantitative
matrix for example the mean iou
at the pixel level so that you can
compare
two segmentations which uh which is more
close to the brown truth
thank you so much dr long this next
question
says and i want to thank again our
audience members for these great
questions coming in
dr long is the transfer learning part of
an entire cnn module or is it
on a per application or training data
set
yeah that's a very good question so uh
transfer learning is actually embedded
in our uh pre-trained model
uh our printing model started from
uh some like uh some initial weights
and those initial weights are not start
started from
did not start from the random uh
assignment
uh it actually started from the uh
retrained uh weights uh derived from
imagenet dataset so that those are
natural images
we use those uh ways to start from and
then trained
on uh like nuclei cell and neurite data
set
and then once we train the model
um we have we provide our customers
the base model for those structures
so the information regarding
very generic uh visual uh features
is already embedded in the image data
sorry imagenet data set and then the
specific
uh features of
the cells nuclei and membranes
are embedded in our base models so those
are
all shaped to our customers and our
customer can use those
base model to fine-tune on their own
data
so when we say transfer learning
actually
it is carrying all the generic
information and the
basic information of cells nuclei and
other structures
to our customers and they can fine-tune
it
thank you so much dr long and does one
always have to have a positive or
negative to do the training because
sometimes one doesn't
know what the phenotype will actually be
can you tell us a little more about that
uh yeah so i will you can um
i i just first explained a little bit
and we can uh
add on uh so our phenoglyphs actually
did not start from uh controlled
uh so it does not did not start from
um the point that you have to know uh
positive or negative or the um
different classes you should assign
the cells to actually started from a
clustering method which is on an
unsupervised method
once using the clustering method
it's um divided data into
different classes and then start from
there
we will introduce the supervise an actor
active learning so the answer is no you
don't have to
uh well do you want something on top of
that
sure yeah if the question's really
specific to
like a classifier like phenoglyphs uh at
least the way we
we designed and built the workflow like
foodway said you
you don't have to start with controls
and it's important to say that it really
is a classifier
so you you don't get some kind of
phenotypic score relative to a
controlled back from it although
you definitely could so so the idea is
that
you use some unsupervised clustering
just to kind of get a sense of of how
the data
is structured and and you kind of decide
in the supervised learning piece how you
want to divide that up
um but one thing that that
you can do and it and it works quite
well is is when you run
uh the clustering you only feed in the
positive and negative control data
because what we find is with the
supervised learning the human's not the
best
kind of being consistent in
differentiating between very subtle
differences and phenotypes
so oftentimes that can lead to a model
that just doesn't doesn't really
train well and come together because the
inconsistencies by the human
so one way to get around that is to just
put in your positive and negative
control into the clustering
usually those are going to be well
separated um
yeah because they're controls um and
build your model off that then apply it
to the rest of the data set
so you don't have to but there are
definitely reasons why it helps
thank you both so much we have time for
a couple of more questions
our next question so what is the readout
of the dl
that was described a list a pca
a umap and with replicates
how does one assess the reproductibility
of the results
that was a that was a complex question
and i'm not seeing it in the
in the q a could you repeat it maybe
sure so what is the readout of the dl
that was described that's the first part
and
um a list a pca a umap
and with replicates how does one assess
the reproductibility of these results
yeah the output of the deep learning is
the
segmented results so if you feed the
deep learning of deep learning module
the cnap
and image then the output is the
segmented results
if you repeat multiple times once the
model is trained if you repeat multiple
times
uh the result is is there it's it's not
changing each time so there's no
randomness inside
uh the randomness only introduced when
you do the training
um so yeah it's
repeatable and the output is the
segmented image
images i hope this address the question
thank you so much and did you want to
add to that will yeah
okay yeah so so i see so yeah so
four-way is correct if
we're talking about um the deep learning
that was mainly focused on here
um it would be a segmentation but i
think a segmentation map
but if if the question was kind of
talking about an approach where you're
learning the features
then then it would make sense right
would you would we
use pca umap disney or something
uh potentially if that's a
question um
i i don't know maybe maybe this isn't on
the question but um one thing that
um kind of interesting is is run run all
of your
your images through network like the
painters network that learns
kind of just really perceive features
use something you map
or tisny um to just plot all the
individual fields of you
so you can visualize them and see how
they cluster together
and yeah
thank you both so much
sure which method of clustering
would you recommend when you want to
discover
how many classes you have in the
segmented population
well yeah so so i think
maybe that's kind of um which method of
clustering so
um so
in with phenoglyphs i i can tell you
that the algorithm that does that
is just k means plus plus but that's
that wasn't chosen
maybe because we thought it was the best
method for for really
doing the clustering that that's more of
a
it facilitates the workflow that we
designed
um but kind of like i just mentioned
disney is
is fine i know that there's reasons why
umap is
is kind of supposed to be a better
method but yeah
thank you so much we have time for one
more question and again thank you
audience for all these great questions
coming in
how many as well as what analysis
is done to show correctness
correctedness
uh yeah this is related to the um
one of the previous questions we just
answered uh in terms of
evaluating the correctness um we have
uh two ways visual check and also
quantitative qualitative adjustment and
also
quantitative evaluations so quality
in terms of the quality we have bio
biologists
working us working working with us
closely they use their biological
knowledge to tell us whether the
segmentation
is correct or or not whether it makes
sense
and we also have quantitative matrix
that evaluate
how close the segmentation result is
compared
to the ground truth
maybe something that would be helpful
okay um just to follow up on that i
think with segmentation i think one of
the
the things that that no one says but it
probably should be said is
there there really is no correct answer
right where's the edge of a cell
i mean this is um it kind of is
how much does it matter so maybe instead
of you know
if you think around an application um
quality um have some known
assay in point and evaluate it against
that
that's kind of what matters as opposed
to pixel pixel
by accuracy usually for for most of the
things we care about
dr fuway long thank you again for your
presentation today and thank you will
for joining us for the q
a and i want to thank our audience for
their outstanding questions
as a final reminder any questions that
were not submitted
or submitted after today's presentation
will be addressed by our speaker via the
address
email that you provided at your
registration and this presentation will
be available for on-demand viewing
in the sbi 2 virtual conference for 12
months
so please remember to share it with your
colleagues who may have missed
today's topic and don't miss out on the
other presentations on our agenda
today thank you again for your
participation until next time
stay safe stay healthy take care bye-bye
thank you bye-bye